we did the first step at FIFA by
increasing significantly the prize money
in our objective is to reach the Equal
Pay uh uh situation in the next World
Cup
but broadcasts especially public
broadcasters funded by taxpayers money
should put their action behind their
words because they rightfully criticize
uh football organizations or other
sports organizations for not paying
equally women
and men are not having the same price
money well we need to generate these
revenues and they should help us because
otherwise we're simply not
sell these rights at these undervalued
prices to them and well the European
public will not be able to watch the
Women's World Cup which after the
success of the last tournament in France
after success of the Euro would be
really really pity